Erica Wernick, Personal Coach, Author and
Speaker: The longer you’ve been in Hollywood
the more rules you are trying to live by but
the thing is that for every rule in Hollywood
there’s always an exception.
Film Courage: What if it’s been five or
ten years and someone’s not any closer to
their quote unquote dream and they come here
from somewhere else?
Erica: I think that question has nuance because
I’ve worked with a lot of people who have
been here for five or ten years who feel nowhere
near their dreams and who are really struggling
but if we’re really honest it’s not like
absolutely nothing has happened in five or
ten years.
Maybe they’re not where they want to be
yet, they haven’t booked that big TV show
yet if they’re an actor or they haven’t
booked that big project (whatever their craft
is) but I don’t think I’ve ever met any
artist out here who literally has not done
a single thing in their career in five or
ten years unless they got a day job that became
their sole priority and then they just worked
on let me get a promotion at my day job let
me try to move up here and that
becomes the priority over the dream and they
kind of let the dream go for all those years
but of my clients that I've worked with I
think it's important to celebrate what you
have achieved and to take like even if you're
not where you want to be and it's been years
take a look at what you've actually done even
if it feels small to you because I think that
if you can start shifting your focus onto
what you have done instead of what you haven't
it'll help you feel more confident it'll help
you feel you know just better energy you'll
feel proud of yourself you'll feel better
and so I think that will lead to more things
happening now that being said you know when
I work with people there's so many things
that we can take a look at it like you know
why are you not where you want to be yet and
so we can take a look at what are the strategies
that you either haven't tried at all or that
you have been procrastinating you know that's
a big thing or that
there's so many pieces sorry I feel like this
is gonna be a long answer but there's so many
pieces to it it's like with the strategy piece
it's like are there things that you haven't
tried and then if there are let's take a look
at why right and that all comes down to your
belief system the fears that you have the
doubts that you have whether or not you believe
in yourself and and that can get very nuanced
as well you know we get deep into what is
really truly holding you back from doing some
of these strategic moves that you really haven't
done yet and then another thing that I've
noticed with some of my clients is that the
longer you have been in the industry and I
always say Hollywood but I don't say Hollywood
as in the location I call like the industry
Hollywood so the longer you've been in Hollywood
if you've been in Hollywood for five or ten
years you end up having more limiting beliefs
than somebody who is brand new because someone
who is brand new they're so green and they're
so naive that they take more risks because
they're not afraid of doing the wrong thing
because they don't know what the wrong thing
is whereas someone who's been here for a long
time and has been in the industry for a long
time you know more about how the industry
works and you might know more about like behind
the scenes and what relationships are important
and what you need to be doing and then because
of that you you lose your sense of risk-taking
and being bold and putting yourself out there
you know in a in a I hate to say in a risky
way but it's all about taking you know it's
all about putting yourself out there and taking
risks and so the longer you've been in Hollywood
the more rules you are trying to live by but
the thing is is that for every rule in Hollywood
there's always an exception so you don't necessarily
want to use these rules to hold you back and
when I say rules just for an example in the
industry you know some of my actor clients
when they are wanting to if they need to get
a new agent or a new manager one of the rules
in Hollywood is you should never contact representation
and reach out to them during pilot season
right there's like certain times of the year
that's busier maybe the beginning of episodic
or you know when pilot season is going on
and you're not supposed to reach out right
and so it's just because you know how the
industry works you've been in the industry
a long time you know that there's a pilot
season you know that people are really busy
during pilot season but there's always going
to be an exception to that rule that rule
is not really set in stone and so if you follow
that rule because you think you're you know
you have this knowledge about how the industry
works and you want to be good and follow these
rules that you think you know in that process
you are stopping yourself from taking a risk
and I've had many clients book agents during
pilot season and then are able to go out for
pilot season so that's just a little example
you know of I think some of the things that
hold people back in Hollywood the more they
know the more it tends to hold them back and
then also with that there's a third part of
this that I've really noticed with some of
my clients is that the more you know the more
boxes you try to fit into and I feel like
that's just a big thing in Hollywood that
a lot of people struggle no matter if you're
a writer a director you know working behind
the scenes somehow an actor you know even
my production designer boss couple years ago
fell into that of like how can I you know
oh I do drama and they don't think I can do
comedy and so I have found that a lot of people
get stuck in these boxes because they're trusting
other people to tell them what box they fit
into you know like with actors it all all
starts in the beginning with headshots I've
seen this so many times where an actor is
told to put their headshot on facebook and
ask everyone on facebook what what roles can
you see me as with this headshot you know
what shows do you see me in according to this
headshot and that's a super common thing right
and if they're not asking their facebook friends
they're asking their agents their managers
their you know their teachers but every time
you do that you are asking somebody else to
tell you how to live your dream and you're
letting somebody else dictate what roles you
go out for what projects you get to be a part
of and you completely lose your voice and
so I think that when people struggle in the
five to ten year range I think that that sometimes
depending on the person you know plays a part
where all these years maybe they've been trying
to pursue the industry in these boxes that
they were told they should be in but it never
feels good and it never feels aligned and
so they struggle you know I have one of my
clients really struggle with that and you
know she's done such beautiful work as we
work together for the past two years and she's
really come into her own right like you know
she's really connected with who she really
is now and who she wants to be and not who
Hollywood has been telling her to be all these
years and then that leads to more exciting
opportunities because you're more confident
and standing on in your own more often and
you know that will bleed into the work that
you do even though it sounds counterintuitive
like oh erica but Hollywood loves the boxes
stepping out of that is somehow going to help
you succeed I think yes I think it's about
alignment and and being yourself a hundred
percent I think that will always lead to more
success I love what you're saying what if
what if we can't accurately see ourselves
because like I knew someone who was was auditioning
and she was doing well and she was about to
turn 30 which when you look back at it from
an older age is not old at all but a friend
or so she thought said oh let me see your
headshots and so she showed this friend and
the friend said oh and he gave her this feedback
he said look you're getting near 30 so you're
going to want to aim for mom rules so maybe
tone down the sexy factor a little bit and
that was sort of eye-opening to this person
because they still saw themselves as this
you know not sex kitten but they just saw
themselves as not as the mom and so i'm just
wondering how much is it that we're blinded
by ourselves because we can't really see ourselves
accurately sometimes or was she allowing this
person to really tell her how to be yeah I
think I mean it's a great question and and
i'm sure that you know every agent or casting
director or whatever will disagree with me
but I think that the more we buy into the
boxes the more we are helping perpetuate the
problem and so I think that you know with
the rise of streamers like netflix and hulu
and amazon we are getting to see more complex
stories which is amazing because with the
networks of abc nbc you know those are likely
following formulas that have worked before
and they're a little more of stereotype when
it comes to characters and content and you
know and story but because there's so much
more content now available with the streaming
I really do feel that we are finally moving
into an area of Hollywood where we are getting
more complex storytelling and so to me like
the mom right you turn 30 and then you need
to play the mom it's like could you be a super
complex character that happens to have a child
right and so I think that we need to stop
letting Hollywood define us as the mom even
if that feels hard you know even if you feel
like you're getting the advice from someone
trusted who's been in the industry I think
it is partly on us to stop perpetuating those
kinds of things that happen you know like
the client that I was talking about she just
came out as non-binary and that can be really
scary as an actor you know because she's having
to explore with her representation what that
means in terms of what roles she wants to
go out for but to her for her to even have
that conversation with her representation
she is breaking through the the boxes and
the Hollywood stuff you know of stereotypes
and she is challenging it because she is saying
this is who I am this is who I know that I
am and so let's explore what kind of complex
roles I can play so I guess to answer your
question about you know finding ourselves
if we feel like maybe we've lost ourselves
I think you have to begin by tuning out everything
tuning out the noise don't listen to me don't
listen to other people you have to get back
to yourself and what your dream truly is you
know the very first chapter of my book I invite
people to write down everything they would
love to happen in their career everything
that you dream of you know get back to that
dream you had in your heart when you were
a kid or whenever it was that you decided
you wanted to pursue this dream get back to
that and connect to that and really you know
some of my clients too they'll they'll study
they'll do some research and watch you know
some shows that they really love and start
to explore what excites them you know when
you watch this do you feel really excited
because you'd love to play a complex role
like this person so I think that process involves
you know you reconnecting with your own intuition
and tuning out the noise and get really true
to who you are and decide that you are worthy
and are capable of succeeding as who you are
even if others tell you no you need to play
the mom or know you need to fit in this box.
What was the most helpful part of this video
for you?